>>> NEW CNN REPORTING ABOUT TH
FIRST UKRAINIAN-BORN MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, INDIANA REPUBLICAN
VICTORIA SPARTZ, SHE'S RUFFLED
SOME FEATHERS IN WASHINGTON WITH
HER CRITICISM OF UKRAINE ANSWER
PRESIDENT AND WHEN A BIPARTISAN
GROUP OF LAWMAKERS VISITED
UKRAINE BACK IN MARCH, SHE
SHOWED UP UNINVITED, ACTING AS
ONE MEMBER PUT IT, LIKE A BULL
IN A CHINA SHOP.
CNN'S MELANIE ZANONA IS LIVE FOR
US IN WASHINGTON.
MEL, TELL US MORE ABOUT THIS.
>> YEAH, SO VICTORIA SPARTZ WAS
INITIALLY SEEN AS A SORT OF
PERFECT MESSENGER FOR THE CAUSE,
SHE IS FROM UKRAINE, SHE'S BEEN
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION TO AID THE
UKRAINE WAR EFFORT, SHE HAS
CHAMPIONED KEY LEGISLATION ON
THAT FRONT BUT OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS SHE'S ALSO BEEN AN
OUTSPOKEN CRITIC OF THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT, HAS
PEDDLED OLD CORRUPTION
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY ANDS SOME OF HIS TOP
AIDES AND SHE HAS SPARKED
ALLEGATIONS FROM HER COLLEAGUES
THAT SHE IS MIRROR ROARING
PRO-RUSSIA TALKING POINTS.
SO THIS IS REALLY ALARMED SOME
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS, LAWMAKERS
IN BOTH PARTIES AND MEMBERS OF
THE UKRAINIAN PARLIAMENT
ACCORDING TO THE REPORTING THAT
I DID WITH MY COLLEAGUE NATASHA
BER
BERTRAND.
THERE HAS BEEN AN EFFORT TO
INTERVENE, THE CONCERN HERE IS
THAT SHE IS UNDERMINING THEIR
EFFORTS TO STAY UNITED BEHIND
UKRAINE AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT.
THEY'RE WORRIED SHE COULD GIVE
ON THE FENCE LAWMAKERS A REASON
TO OPPOSE THE NEXT AID PACKAGE.
SOME TOP REPUBLICANS HAVE TRIED
TO PRIVATELY TALK TO HER TO
REIGN HER IN, WE'RE ALSO TOLD
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION GAVE HER
AN INTELLIGENCE BRIEFING AND
TRIED TO WALK HER THROUGH SOME
ALLEGATIONS SHE'S MADE AND
REFUTE THEM OR EXPLAIN THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THEM.
OVER THE COURSE OF REPORTING WE
ALSO LEARNED SHE SHOWED UP
UNINVITED TO A CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION TRIP EARLIER THIS
YEAR TO UKRAINE WHERE ONE GOP
LAWMAKER SAID SHE ACTED LIKE A
BULL IN A CHINA SHOP, SHE WAS
ACCUSATORY AND RUDE DURING THE
TRIP, BUT VICTORIA SPARTZ IS
PUSHING BACK ON THAT
DESCRIPTION.
SHE SAID TO US IN AN EMAIL THIS
ACCUSATION IS A COWARDLY
MISREPRESENTATION OF FACTS BY
SOME JEALOUS MEMBERS OR STAFF.
SINCE WE HAD A VERY PRODUCTIVE
BIPARTISAN CODEL IN MARCH.
SHE ALSO SAID ON HER OUTSPOKEN
CRITICISMS OF THE UKRAINE
GOVERNMENT THAT I ALSO DARE
DEEPLY ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVES.
I CANNOT LET THEM DOWN, EVEN IF
THAT MEANS SAYING UNPOPULAR
TRUTHS THAT OFFEND THE
POLITICIANS OR DIVERGE FROM THE
POPLAR NARRATIVE OF THE DAY.
DESPITE THIS EFFORT TO REIGN HER
IN THERE ARE NO SIGNS THAT
VICTORIA SPARTZ IS BACKING DOWN.
>> WHAT A BIZARRE STORY.
WE KNOW YOU WILL KEEP WORKING ON
THAT.
MELANIE ZANONA, THANK YOU.